y emoción en sí porque en este vídeo
hablaremos de una de las leyes más
importantes de toda la ciencia la ley de
la conservación de la energía se
asombrarán por lo mucho que podemos
inferir en el universo basándonos en la
ley de la conservación de la energía se
asombrarán de cuantas interrogantes se
han explicado en la ciencia ficción
basándose en la ley de la conservación
de la energía empecemos con el lenguaje
que comúnmente podemos encontrar y
después tratemos de entenderlo a un
nivel más profundo
aquí nos dicen que la energía total de
un sistema aislado es constante la
energía no se crea ni se destruye sólo
se transforma de una forma a otra o se
transfiere de un sistema a otro
prácticamente subraya toda la definición
porque todo es muy importante para
entender esto pensemos en los tipos de
energía que hemos estudiado ya hemos
estudiado la energía cinética que es la
energía que poseen los objetos en
movimiento
también hemos hablado de la energía
potencial que la podemos ver cómo la
energía asociada a la posición de un
cuerpo en reposo y a la combinación de
estos dos tipos de energías se le conoce
como energía mecánica energía mecánica
cuando estudiamos física por primera vez
estos son los dos tipos de energías en
las que nos enfocamos pero existen otros
tipos de energías existe la energía
térmica la energía nuclear la energía
química así que como estas energías no
son las únicas puede ser que en algún
caso la energía cinética se transforme
en energía química
pero no hablaremos de esos tipos de
energía en este vídeo para entender
mejor todo esto primero pensemos en cómo
se puede conservar la energía mecánica
podemos verla como la ley de la
conservación de la energía mecánica pero
después haremos las cosas un poco más
complicadas y veremos si podemos
desafiar de alguna manera a la ley de la
conservación de la energía así que deben
de ser muy escépticos de cualquiera que
afirme que puede desafiar a la ley de la
conservación de la energía bueno
empecemos con un sistema que consiste en
una pelota que cae a la superficie del
planeta tierra vamos a llamarlo sistema
tierra pelota cuando trabajamos con la
ley de la conservación de la energía es
importante que especificamos el sistema
y vamos a suponer que este es un sistema
aislado que no interactúa mucho con
otros sistemas externos como el sol o
algo por el estilo entonces aquí ha
dibujado la superficie terrestre
pero ahora vamos a dibujar nuestra
pelota supongamos que la pelota se
encuentra aquí inicialmente en la pelota
se encuentra en reposo y vamos a suponer
que aquí no hay aire entonces mientras
la pelota se encuentra en reposo la
energía total es potencial la podemos
llamar energía potencial gravitacional
entonces toda la energía es potencial el
símbolo de la energía potencial es
mayúscula y podemos decir que esta es la
energía potencial gravitacional también
podemos decir que no hay energía
cinética no hay energía cinética
si hablamos de nuestro sistema en
general es decir si en este caso
hablamos del sistema solar o algo
parecido sabemos que la tierra órbita
alrededor del sol y a su vez el sol
órbita alrededor del centro de la
galaxia por eso es que tenemos que ser
muy específicos este es un sistema en el
que estudiamos una pelota en el planeta
tierra
ahora qué pasa si dejamos caer la pelota
y especialmente qué tipo de energía
predomina en la pelota justo cuando ésta
toca el suelo bueno para eso vamos a
suponer que toca el suelo y no rebota
porque eso complicaría mucho las cosas
entonces en este caso podemos decir que
si dejamos caer la pelota
instantáneamente ya no tenemos energía
potencial gravitacional y justo cuando
la pelota toca el suelo justo en ese
momento tiene mucha energía cinética así
que la energía total es cinética en este
caso podemos ver que justo cuando la
pelota toca el suelo toda la energía
potencial se transforma en energía
cinética y tal vez se estén preguntando
pero qué pasa después de ese momento
bueno si esta pelota no rebota y
solamente se queda ahí pareciera que la
pelota ya no tiene energía como si la
energía hubiera sido destruida pero me
gustaría preguntarles a ustedes
donde se fue esa energía no sé en el
vídeo y piénsenlo un poco tal vez
algunos de ustedes digan una vez que la
pelota golpea el suelo se queda en
reposo entonces tal vez hemos encontrado
un caso que desafía a la ley de la
conservación de la energía bueno
recuerden sean muy escépticos sobre
cualquiera que alguna vez les diga eso
en este caso la energía más bien se ha
disipado se convirtió en calor pudo
haberse transformado en energía térmica
así que la pelota y el suelo se
calientan debido a esa energía cinética
que justo cuando la pelota toca el suelo
se convierte en energía térmica por lo
tanto no hemos desafiado a la ley de la
conservación de la energía ahora otra
cosa que podemos decir es que imaginando
un mundo en el que tenemos aire voy a
dibujar algunas partículas de aire por
aquí sabemos que conforme la pelota cae
al suelo esta pasa a través del aire así
que podemos considerar la resistencia
del aire
como algunos le llaman fricción por el
aire bueno eso haría que la caída de la
pelota fuera más lenta por lo que al
caer no existiría tanta energía cinética
entonces parecería que en esa situación
la energía cinética es destruida pero
nuevamente mi respuesta es no la energía
cinética no se destruye conforme la
pelota cae porque en realidad eso
calienta la pelota y al aire que se
encuentra alrededor así que la
resistencia del aire actúa como una
fuerza de rozamiento o fricción que
disipa la energía cinética y resulta en
la generación de energía térmica pero si
queremos escribir esto como una ecuación
hay un par de formas en las que podemos
hacerlo vamos a ver si únicamente
escribimos la ley de la conservación de
la energía mecánica sin hablar de la
fuerza de rozamiento o fricción podemos
decir que la energía cinética inicial
la energía potencial inicial es igual a
la energía cinética final más la energía
potencial final otra forma de escribir
esto es diciendo que el cambio de
energía cinética más el cambio de
energía potencial es igual a cero
suponiendo que no tenemos ninguna fuerza
de fricción y que no se transforma en
otras fuerzas como la energía química o
la energía térmica pero si quisiéramos
incluir las fuerzas de fricción que
disipan la energía
entonces es importante decir que este
tipo de fuerzas generan algo conocido
como trabajo no conservativa y podemos
decir que realizan un trabajo negativo
porque la fuerza de fricción siempre
actúa en la dirección opuesta al
movimiento vamos a reescribir estas
ecuaciones aquí vamos a escribir la
energía cinética inicial más la energía
potencial inicial más cualquier trabajo
realizado por cualquier fuerza no
conservativa
como es el caso de la resistencia del
aire o la fricción esto será negativo y
esto es igual a la energía cinética
final más la energía potencial final o
en este caso podemos escribirlo como el
cambio de energía cinética más el cambio
de energía potencial y eso es igual al
trabajo realizado por las fuerzas de
rozamiento o fricción y recuerden que
como estamos hablando de una fuerza de
fricción esto será negativo otra forma
en la que podríamos haber pensado esto
sería en términos de la energía térmica
en este caso podríamos decir que el
cambio de la energía cinética más el
cambio de la energía potencial más el
cambio de la energía térmica es igual a
cero o podríamos incluir el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza de fricción
bien así que si por ejemplo nos
encontramos con una situación en donde
el cambio total de energía mecánica
fuera negativo no podemos definir la ley
de la conservación de la energía
porque en ese caso no es que la energía
fuera destruida sino que tenemos este
trabajo negativo realizado por las
fuerzas de fricción pero a dónde se va
esa energía bueno la energía simplemente
se transforma en energía térmica hagamos
algunos ejemplos para entenderlo mejor
hagamos un sistema tierra péndulo aquí
tenemos el suelo y después tenemos una
especie de torre de la que cuelga
nuestro péndulo aquí tenemos el péndulo
y en el punto más bajo la pelota llega
aquí y después vuelve a subir y
supongamos que la diferencia de altura
entre este punto y este es igual h
entonces podemos decir que este es el
punto más alto al que llegará el péndulo
así que en este punto tenemos la energía
potencial máxima porque justo cuando va
a cambiar su dirección no hay energía
cinética ya que el péndulo se queda
estático por un momento pero después el
péndulo regresa y cuando pasa por este
punto todo
energía potencial se ha convertido en
energía cinética claro suponiendo que
parte de la energía no se ha disipado en
otras formas como la fuerza de fricción
y después toda esa energía cinética se
convierte nuevamente en energía
potencial otro ejemplo que podemos
analizar y que complica a este un poco
más es pensar en un sistema tierra
pelota resorte aquí tenemos la
superficie terrestre después tenemos el
resorte y por acá tenemos a la pelota
que empieza en estado estacionario así
que podemos decir que inicialmente la
energía total es potencial gravitacional
y suponiendo que no tenemos ninguna
resistencia del aire dejamos caer la
pelota y justo antes de que ésta toque
el resorte es decir cuando alcanza la
velocidad máxima ahora toda la energía
cinética pero después la pelota comprime
el resorte y suponiendo que no tenemos
ninguna generación de energía térmica
pero no olviden que en el mundo
siempre hay generación de energía
térmica si este resorte se comprime y la
pelota llega a este punto entonces
podemos decir que una parte de la
energía se ha convertido en energía
potencial elástica porque al comprimir
el resorte en algún momento regresará a
su posición original y la energía
volverá a transformarse en energía
cinética y la energía potencial
gravitacional nos vemos en otro vídeo